my koi is one of Viet Nam's best snow
musicians a former darling of the
country's ruling Communist Party her
songwriting was nationally celebrated
and she was the poster girl for Vietnam
today she is an enemy of the state and
lives in constant fear for her life my
shows were shipped down
I was evident from my house was under
surveillance 24/7
[Music]
in 2010 I want the highest award of
musicians in Vietnam if you get that
word everyone will know you and the
government used myself to promote for
the country's image music has always
been closely monitored by Viet Nam's
communist regime during the Vietnam War
music that did not promote communist
ideas was banned today the few
songwriters who dare to directly
challenge the authority of the regime
face serious consequences
[Applause]
[Music]
I was resisting social norms about what
it means to be a Vietnamese woman I
wrote a song about woman's freedom I
caused the national scandal for saying I
don't want to have children and not
wearing a bra I couldn't feel free to
create art and making music and I start
to spend time with dissident artists
that's the way I am now my koi started
to be monitored by the regime President
Obama I want to meet you when you come
to Vietnam in May before the visit of
the then US President Barack Obama in
2016 my koi sent a plea to him to
discuss the state of human rights in the
country we have a very popular artist
here who was speaking out on behalf of
freedom of speech and expression and
artists throughout Vietnam the meeting
led to police raids of her concerts if
they don't like the lyrics of the song
they will ask you to repeal the song
from the album
the censorship system in Vietnam censor
everything because they want to control
people thought despite sweeping economic
and social reforms in Vietnam the ruling
Communist Party retains tight media
censorship and does not tolerate
criticism year vietnam ranked in the
bottom six of one hundred and eighty
countries for press freedom arrests of
democracy campaigners bloggers and
activists have escalated in the past
year vietnam is a one body state that
doesn't allow any political opposition
we don't have freedom of speech we don't
have freedom of expression we don't have
freedom of assembly a controversial
cybersecurity law was introduced this
year forcing internet companies to
remove contents the authorities deemed
to be against the Vietnamese state tech
giants such as Facebook and Google have
to hand over user data if asked by the
Vietnamese government when we have
social media we have the only small
space to feel free to speak but now
under the cybersecurity laws we cannot
do that anymore
[Music]
despite constant surveillance and
threats of imprisonment my COI still
lives in Vietnam and she continues to
use her voice to advocate for a fairer
society I have a mission I need to sing
out what I've seen
[Music]
as an artist we have to miss him to
speak with for
unexpectable voice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]